isn't it funny how you watch some
episodes and then forget them almost
like that overdue Doctor Who review and
this time it's time to talk about the
long game this is an episode that I
think I have me not revisited it for the
first time in a long time because it's
just not an episode I fell to any
particular desire to have a really watch
again I think I've seen it maybe twice
prior to this and I don't even know how
long it's been I think it might actually
be a bit over maligned if I'm being
honest now I'm not about to defend the
upso but it's not so much bad as it is
frustrating it is a frustrating viewing
experience for a number of reasons so
the first big thing and I'm not really
going to recap the plot if you're
watching a review of something this old
this late I'm assuming you've already
seen this and I'm gonna get into
spoilers right off so there are elements
and there are ideas that are really good
and then under utiliser under explored
so Simon Pegg as the editor I think he's
a great villain and I also love how his
attitude and his interactions with
characters feeds into an idea that
exists in this episode that is almost
not explored at all because the whole
notion of a society we're broadcasting a
lie is actually a crime lying about who
you are is a crime and yet the people at
the top are not themselves honest even
though they are enforcing honesty with
every forcibly with everybody else that
is a concept ripe for satire for you
know sort of deeply looking at the
relationship that
we that as a society we have with the
truth the relationship that the news has
with with the truth and the supposed
objectivity that you know gets enforced
but is still in some way subjective
still pushing agenda if only by what
gets emphasis and what gets omitted like
there's just so much to work with there
it just kind of skims past the surface
of it so that we can get a monster in
the ceiling it's really frustrating
because i reaiiy do think that that idea
is something that could yield a great
satirical episode it's the kind of thing
that I would really love to see Big
Finish tackle if they haven't already
because it's the kind of broader more
philosophical idea that I don't mean to
knock you know Doctor Who episodes but
it they they do they explore those ideas
more often in Big Finish than they do in
the actual show at this point which is
not intended as an arc on the show I
think that's actually more of a function
of time most Big Finish stories are
about two hours that's the proper amount
of time to explore something like that
as opposed to about 45 minutes which is
all this has but even if it only had 45
minutes if it had trimmed off some of
the fat it could have explored these
ideas more deeply so what is some of the
fad well there's Adam for one thing and
I've talked about him before like I
don't I don't hate Adam functionally
because like I understand why he's there
in terms of making the point that roses
ability to deal with this and act
appropriately is not Universal and
that's someone who appeared to be clever
by today's standards throw them into
this situation they can be really dumb
really self-centered just really have
crap not go well so I think that that
was a decent way to sort of bolster Rose
a little bit not that Rose was like
coming across as not a good fit for the
doctor but it's nice to sort of
emphasize like well he can't just take
anybody because some people screw this
up badly so like I get that but by
devoting so much time of this story to
him and to making that point which again
I'm not
Kitely sure was point that needed to be
made like it's not an invalid one to
make I suppose especially with the
revival but because the story has to
share time with that that is the kind of
thing that is eating up time as opposed
to deep diving into these concepts into
these ideas and it is such a shame
because I do I love any time the editor
is like something's fictional or he's
like who's that there but I don't know
something it's so nice not to know
something and you know the smugness of
that what he's talking to Suki and he's
like going through her biographies like
liar liar and I love those interactions
and I love what that implies about this
society in this structure and how it
works and we just don't get much out of
it the doctor himself is not a little
I'm not gonna say he's off but this is
probably I'd say the most underwhelming
performance that Eccleston gives it's
not a bad performance but he doesn't get
a lot to work with he's just kind of
like Oh things are a little off and he
doesn't he doesn't have as many moments
to shine as he usually does because
Eccleston was definitely a doctor who
whenever there was any moment for him to
like grab and get and get a good beat
out of he would and they're just as much
for him to work with here I think my
favorite moment with him is Rose turned
to him say is there trouble and he just
goes yeah and he smiles like oh there it
is oh it's gone like that was his one
very brief shining moment although I
will say I do like the nature of sort of
the arc between him and the and the
reporter whose name I've now forgotten
sort of makes my point this episode is
really hard to hold on to a lot of the
details of it's quite forgettable but
the one who helps him at the end and
cathica so I think that's it I might
have a wrong that I'm going with that so
like I do like that interaction that the
doctor doesn't like save the satellite
he gets one person to wake up to what
they should have been doing the whole
time and then they make that step and I
actually like that night kind of
wish doctor who would do that more often
modern doctor who has a tendency to
overemphasize the doctor sort of
finagling things so that the enemy's
plan defeats itself I don't think well
maybe it maybe it happens more often
than I think it's just in episodes that
I wish were better I guess I'll find out
as I go through these things but my
feeling is that it's not as common that
he finagles things so that the humans
actually do what they were supposed to
be doing and elevates them I mean he
lectures humans a lot I don't mean
Eccleston specifically made the doctor
in general lectures humans a lot about
what they should be doing and he tells a
little bit here but I don't feel like he
he gives as much of an encouragement and
a and a and a sense of they came to the
conclusion of what they should be doing
with a little help but at least
partially on their own and I think a lot
of times it feels just much more oh they
realized the doctors right and they just
do what he wants them to do and this if
that's a little more earned in terms of
her own coming to a sense of things I
liked her as well she was a good
presence there's also I'm gonna
highlight something here because I've
been meaning to make a video about this
sort of thing happening and I still
might but if I do I need to remember to
use this as an example so one of the
things that will often drive me crazy is
when I make a complaint about something
and people defend it because there's a
narrative justification for it so what
I'll cite here is especially compared to
the last time that we went off for
awhile
offworld like in orbit around Earth way
far off world the last time we went off
world it was for the end of the world
and we got all these fantastic creatures
this wonderful look and that sense of
scope and scale to the universe because
even though we haven't left the orbit of
Earth we're seeing all these wonderful
and amazing aliens and cool concepts and
different cultures we're getting a taste
of all that none of that here here we're
on a satellite with a bunch of people
acting like this modern-day earth and I
know that the dog that's part of what
cues the doctor off
something's wrong but that's kind of my
point narrative Li they justify that the
jagrafess is has manipulated things to
cut off humanity from other societies
they do justify the lack of anything
other than humans but that doesn't
change the fact that this feels just
like an underwhelming setting because
it's all humans especially when our
other point of comparison was the end of
the world it's still a step down it's
still something that makes the show feel
less than it could have been even though
you can justify it narrowly narrative Li
so that's one of the things that drives
me crazy explaining why something is the
way it is doesn't mean that suddenly
that thing works so yeah so there's that
going on and Isis do suspect the
logistical reason why there are no
aliens than this is because they
couldn't afford them and they they sunk
their budgets elsewhere in other
episodes so you know I get I get the
logistical reasons as well but it's just
it's just one of those things that
annoys me so I'm not sure what else
there is to say really I'm glad that
they ditch Adam by the end of this
because and they should because he
served his purpose I have sometimes
wondered if it would be probably too
much time has passed now it's too far to
call back to but I always did kind of
wonder would he turn up again like I
when when Harry Jones turned up again
there was part of me that wondered is he
gonna be like a science consultant for
her or you know I've seen some people
propose that he comes back flat-out as a
villain because he's got a grudge
against the doctor and that might be a
little much but I was kind of wondered
about the possibilities of bringing him
back probably won't happen at this place
I'm not sure I would want it to and I'm
not even necessarily gonna call it a
missed opportunity because I don't think
you need to bring him back but I don't
know I wonder sometimes I think I think
that's about it really it's it's a it's
an episode with potential in its core
concepts and in some of the performances
but at the end of the day it just it
feels like filler the monster feels like
filler it's like the epitome of insert
monster here they do way too much
build-up for what is literally just a
mouth in the ceiling and you know the
the whole thing just feels like well we
need to seed a few things that are gonna
pay off at the end of the series what's
a story that will allow us to do that
well here it's functional that's what
the long game is the long game is
functional and that's kind of it but
yeah not not as bad as I kind of
remember it but a bit more frustrating
then I remember it but in any case
that'll wrap up my thoughts on the long
game what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of buttons and links and
stuff down there as well check them out
if you feel like it
including the patreon link so you know
if you want to take a look at those go
for it if not don't worry about it
because remember folks you're the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]